[Musica]
era una notte fredda di febbraio c'erano
meno 25 gradi e mi trovavo a quota 5000
metri a quell'altezza c'è molto meno
ossigeno manca il respiro bisogna
camminare al rallentatore ogni passo
sembra un chilometro mancano le forze
quella notte c'era la luna piena ma non
riusciva nemmeno ad alzare gli occhi al
cielo l'unica cosa che riusciva a fare
era guardarmi punta dei piedi dovevo
investire tutte le mie energie per
mettere un piede davanti all'altro nella
mia testa c'erano due voci una diceva
molla l'altra diceva coraggio ce la puoi
fare un altro passo mi trovavo sul
kilimangiaro e mancavano poche decine di
metri alla vetta quella vetta per me era
diventata un simbolo un simbolo di
rinascita
avevo deciso di scalarlo un anno prima
mentre mi trovavo nel mezzo di un
periodo nero avevo avuto una caduta
clamorosa che mi aveva scaraventata sul
fondo del book buco più buio e fetido
che avessi mai visto in vita mia io lo
chiamo il voto il vuoto è un posto fatto
di dolore e autocommiserazione tanta
autocommiserazione non ha né forma né
spazio né tempo
il vuoto è una non esistenza che ti
mangia viva e niente lo può colmare
perché il vuoto sei tu stavo talmente
male che mi sembrava quasi di non sapere
nemmeno più come si facesse a camminare
talmente male che la parola felicità mi
faceva infuriare perché mi sembrava una
presa in giro una bugia poi un amico mi
ha detto una frase che ha cambiato tutto
perché nel momento in cui
l'ho capita
ho iniziato a muovere i primi passi
verso direzione star bene e mi sono
promessa che da lì un anno non solo mi
sarei rimessa in piedi e sarei tornata
in me avrei anche ritrovato quella
felicità in cui non credevo più e
siccome mi piacciono le sfide sobria per
celebrare avrebbe scalato il
kilimangiaro convinta che una volta
arrivata in vetta avrei finalmente
capito tutto quella frase era la
felicità è una scelta
l'ho scritta su un post it che ho
attaccato accanto al mio letto e da quel
giorno mela ripeto ogni mattina prima di
alzarlo felicità è una parola ampiamente
abusata di questi tempi carica di
bellezza ma anche di tutta una serie di
pressioni che finiscono quasi per
ottenere l'effetto opposto perché
ammettiamolo non è facile essere felici
abbiamo tutti le nostre montagne da
scalare per alcuni la montagna è
cambiare lavoro cambiare percorso per un
viaggio che si sognava da tanto avere un
figlio prendere casa affrontare una
malattia dirà qualcuno che lo amiamo
lasciare andare qualcuno che non abbiamo
più mollare tutto e ricominciare da zero
per altri la montagna è semplicemente
alzarsi dal letto la mattina
nonostante tutti i motivatori e duro
improvvisati che invadono il web con
articoli che ci dicono come essere
felici sempre e si atteggiano a coloro
che hanno le chiavi dell'universo in
realtà nessuno ci capisce molto
non si può googlare come essere felici e
aspettarsi una risposta plausibile
poi la società in cui viviamo non è che
ci facilita proprio le cose è una
società che distrugge tutto e tutti in
nome del progresso una società basata
sul consumo chiedo la tra il successo
che viene misurato in soldi status
numero di followers e che felici dalla
perfezione e spoiler alert la perfezione
non esiste e ci dice continuamente che
dobbiamo fare apparire per formare avere
desiderare accumulare creando così falsi
bisogni che ci spingono a volere sempre
di più come se non bastasse il tutto
illustrato filtrato e distorto dai
social dove tutti gli altri sembrano
felici sempre
tutto questo l'ho capito anche grazie al
mio lavoro che mi ha portato a vedere
tanta felicità ma anche tanta infelicità
sono una storia altra parola ncha mente
accusata di questi tempi dopo una
carriera come fotografa di moda a new
york carriera che mi rendeva infelice e
piena di sensi di colpa
ho deciso di mollare tutto iniziare a
viaggiare in solitaria e ho cambiato
rotta oggi sono una fotografa
documentarista faccio video scrivo
viaggio tanto e per guadagnarmi da
vivere racconto storia racconta storie
di luoghi e di culture diverse la nostra
ma soprattutto storia di persone negli
ultimi anni ho lavorato principalmente
in asia in africa spesso su progetti
umanitari
e inter visto molte persone e facciano a
tutti le stesse domande domande semplici
dove vive in cosa mangi quali sono le
tue difficoltà quali sono i tuoi sogni
cosa ti rende felice e le risposte a
quest'ultima domanda spesso sono
straordinarie nella loro semplicità per
questo signore a cuba suonare per questa
donna in birmania android sono una zona
dove non cresce niente e leone g le
hanno insegnato a coltivare tramite le
serre idroponiche per lei è poter
raccogliere le sue verdure per questa
famiglia sempre mm è poter mettere il
cibo in tavola per i propri figli
per questa donna in marocco è poter
mandare a scuola la figlia
per questa ragazza sarà una ragazza ma
sai che ha iniziato ad andare a scuola
solo l'anno prima quando aveva 15 anni
per lei è poter ricevere un'istruzione
per questa donna in tanzania e potersi
mettere dei vestiti puliti la mattina
quante di queste cose diamo per scontate
qualche mese fa ero in iraq per
documentare le storie di bambini e
adolescenti che vivono nei campi per
rifugiati del kurdistan
le persone che vivono nei campi hanno
perso tutto si sono dovuti lasciare alle
spalle la loro casa la loro vita i loro
affetti e nonno perché in cerca di un
futuro migliore ma per scappare dall
isis per rimanere vivi hanno visto
errori che per fortuna molti di noi non
riescono nemmeno ad immaginarsi e oggi
vivono bloccati in un campo e le loro
vite sono sospese in un limbo continua
di incertezza ad alcuni dei ragazzini
che ho intervistato ho chiesto se
potessi esprimere un desiderio 1 cosa
chiederesti e le risposte sono state
tornare a casa
tornare a scuola
rivedere la mia famiglia
che ci sia pace
quante di queste cose diamo per scontate
da questa parte di mondo
viaggiando e documentando le vite degli
altri ho capito quanto fosse davvero
fortunata ad essere nata dove sono nata
ad avere un passaporto che mi permette
di viaggiare andare praticamente ovunque
ad aver ricevuto un'istruzione ad avere
dei diritti che vengono tutelati ad
avere la possibilità di scegliere cosa
fare nella mia vita tutte cose che prima
davo per scontate
c'è gente al mondo che non ha niente di
tutto questo gente che non ha scelta
gente che non è libera di scegliere noi
in occidente quella scelta l'abbiamo
certo abbiamo tutti le nostre difficoltà
i nostri dolori i nostri problemi da
superare però la scelta
ce l'abbiamo la scelta di star bene ce
l'abbiamo e sta solo nelle nostre mani
eppure si bravissimi ad essere infelici
passando molto tempo in asia ho iniziato
ad appassionarmi alle filosofie
orientali che guardano alla vita in
maniera completamente diversa da come la
vediamo noi noi tendiamo a cercare la
felicità all'esterno se avrò quella cosa
quel lavoro quella persona quel numero
di follower allora sarò felice mentre
per molte altre culture la felicità può
essere cercata e trovata solo
all'interno e sapete perché perché loro
tengono in considerazione è qualcosa che
per la nostra società non ha
praticamente valore ma chi invece
l'unico vero luogo da cui attingere alla
felicità l'anima
c'è un nemico numero uno della nostra
anima che è il nostro ego leggono un gol
meglio per noi leggo non si vuole bene
non ci vuole non vuole che noi ci
vogliamo bene e quindi fa tutta una
serie di cose che ci fanno far male e
quindi ci prendono infelici
la prima è guardare le mancanze invece
che quello che già si sa
[Musica]
invece che concentrarsi e disperarci per
quello che non abbiamo se riuscissimo ad
essere grati per quello che già abbiamo
la vita intorno a noi cambierebbe
completamente si trasformerebbe perché
la gratitudine e il primo vero passo
fondamentale verso una vita felice una
mancanza che invece ci fa star male è la
mancanza di significato nella propria
vita e questa è strettamente legata come
passiamo il nostro tempo e quindi anche
al lavoro abbiamo l'idea che il lavoro
debba essere qualcosa di faticoso
spiacevole fatto solo per fare soldi ma
lavoro occupa gran parte del nostro
tempo e il tempo la risorsa più preziosa
che abbiamo è importante cercare di
farne uno che ci piaccia che ci stimoli
o almeno che abbia un senso per noi
perché non siamo qui solo per pagare le
bollette e morire
un modo il modo migliore per trovare il
significato nella propria vita e farsi
delle domande le domande grosse ma io
chi sono che cosa ci faccio qui qui in
questo strano posto chiamato vita
una cosa che invece piace tanto allego
ma che ci fa malissimo è il controllo
basta guardare come viviamo il tempo
stiamo male per il passato che non c'è
più e ci disperiamo e ci preoccupiamo
per il futuro che non esiste è
un'illusione non abbiamo nessun
controllo sul futuro solo sul momento
presente il famoso qui e ora e su come
reagiamo a quello che ci sta succedendo
adesso il controllo non esiste l'unica
cosa che possiamo controllare in questo
mondo in questa vita su questa terra
siamo noi stessi possiamo controllare e
scegliere come passiamo il nostro tempo
e con chi come investiamo il nostro
denaro e le nostre energie quello di cui
ci nutriamo il cibo che ci mettiamo in
corpo i libri che leggiamo quello che
guardiamo le persone che seguiamo online
e so che sembra assurdo ma fidatevi è
possibile possiamo controllare i nostri
pensieri quando un pensiero negativo
arriva possiamo scegliere di lasciarlo
andare invece che seguirlo nella sua
spirale autodistruttiva
per vivere bene bisogna lasciar andare
il controllo come avendo fede che tutto
andrà come deve andare che tutto succede
per una ragione
un altro fattore di sofferenza è il
condizionamento ogni giorno ci vengono
buttate addosso informazioni opinioni
giudizi altrui
e se li ascoltiamo va a finire che non
riusciamo più a sentire l'unica cosa che
conta davvero nella nostra vita quella
che io chiamo la voce ce l'abbiamo
dentro tutti c'è chi la chiama istinto
intuito anima è una vocina rompipalle
che più che dai pensieri viene dalle
viscere e solo lei sa cosa è meglio per
noi
vi faccio un esempio magari tu vuoi fare
non so l'illustratrice però i tuoi
genitori ti convincono a fare
giurisprudenza non vuoi deluderli così
prendi e continui su quella strada che
però ti fa schifo perché non era la
strada giusta per te perché qualcun
altro l'ha scelta per te così piano
piano inizia a stare male ti senti in
trappola incastrata persa senza
significato perché stai vivendo la vita
di qualcun altro ti sei tradita
non tutti riescono ad ascoltare la
propria voce perchè c'è troppo rumore
intorno bisogna imparare ad e
condizionare il pensiero da quello degli
altri a sbattersene nel giudizio degli
altri a circondarsi di silenzio ogni
tanto e ascoltarsi nel profondo ma nella
testa perché la mente mente ma nel cuore
e seguire la propria voce ovunque ci
porterà anche se ciò richiede un cambio
di rotta perché solo così si trova la
propria strada
solo così si riesce ad essere se stessi
ed essere se stessi rimanere veri a se
stessi e la libertà il successo più
grande di tutti a volte però non
riusciamo a seguire nella nostra voce
perché viene sovrastata da quella della
paura ma la paura è una bugiarda ladra
di sogni che non ha niente da offrire
l'unica cosa che ha da dire no stai
ferma non fare niente e se la si ascolta
si finisce per vivere una non vita
perché il rischio è necessario se si
vuole vivere davvero in tanti mi dicono
che sono coraggiosa in realtà sono solo
una persona molto curiosa sono curiosa
di vedere dove mi porterà la vita di
vedere come va e se cado e se mi faccio
male
almeno sono provato e alla fine dei miei
giorni potrò guardare indietro e senza
rimpianti dire wow quanto vissuto
essere coraggiosi non vuol dire non
avere paura vuol dire avere una paura
folle ma farlo comunque vuol dire
ascoltare quella voce che ti dice
coraggio un altro passo e questo ci
riporta sul kilimangiaro quella notte ho
scelto di ascoltare la voce che mi
diceva di fare un altro passo e sono
arrivata in cima sulla vetta tanto
sognata e sapete cosa è successo quando
sono arrivata in cima e stato bellissimo
una soddisfazione immensa ma poi sono
dovuta scendere
perché non si può rimanere sulla vetta
per sempre e così è la vita non si può
essere felici sempre la felicità è uno
stato transitorio come l'equilibrio ma
esiste bisogna ricordarselo sempre
aspirare c e non serve scalare una
montagna vera e propria per toccarla
basta camminare mettendo un piede
davanti all'altro
non ha senso voler scalare una montagna
per arrivare in cima piantarci sopra una
bandierina la vera soddisfazione da
raggiungere una vetta sta nella fatica
che si è fatta durante il cammino e in
quello che si è visto vissuto ho
imparato durante il cammino e camminando
si scopre una parola che secondo me è
molto più bella umile e tangibile di
felicità o equilibrio armonia armonia
tra mente corpo e anima tra gioia e
dolore tra luce e ombra perché alla fine
non c'è l'una senza l'altra armonia e
quella vera vetta da raggiungere e ce
l'abbiamo dentro da sempre
parafrasando la watts
invece che interpretare la vita come un
viaggio con una meta specifica o come
una montagna con una vetta da
raggiungere dovremo interpretarla come
qualcosa di giocoso con una musica o una
danza perché il punto di una sinfonia
non è arrivare alla fine ma suonarla il
punto di una danza non è arrivare in un
punto specifico del pavimento ma ad
alzarla invece fin da piccoli ci mettono
in testa la vita sia una sorta di
pellegrinaggio verso il raggiungimento
di una meta e lo scopo di arrivare a
quella metà che sia successo la pensione
magari paradiso dopo la morte e poi
arriveremo alla fine e ci accorgeremo
che per tutto il tempo c'era sfuggito il
punto era una melodia e dovevamo
cantarla o ballarla finché la musica
veniva suonata
alla fine io non ci ho ancora capito
molto di che cosa ci faccio qui
ma faccio meglio che posso per
continuare a scegliere di ballare ogni
giorno un passo alla volta e auguro lo
stesso anche a voi banco rush
[Applauso]